while US presidential candidates are
busy arguing and discussing their junk
by the end of this month between 500,000
and 1 million Americans will be
struggling to afford food a major change
to snap or food stamps as most people
know it is going to mean that hundreds
of thousands of Americans will stop
getting food assistance if they can't
find a job and the people who'll be hurt
the most well the majority of Americans
on food assistance make an income that
amounts to about 17 percent of the
poverty line
that's only $2,000 a year over 40
percent are women one-third are over 40
and half only have a high school diploma
or GED a quarter haven't even completed
high school in short they're the people
most likely to struggle to find work
particularly in areas of the country
where the economic recovery hasn't been
as strong so what exactly is happening
with snap that's going to leave maybe up
to 1 million Americans unable to afford
food well let's take you back to the
welfare reform Act of 1996 signed by
President Bill Clinton the rules of the
program said that non-disabled adults
between the ages of 18 and 49 who don't
have any dependents could only get food
assistance for three months while
unemployed and to continue to get money
they'd have to either be working in job
training or doing voluntary work fair
labor for at least 20 hours per week and
then the 2008 financial crash happened
and Congress signed a high unemployment
waiver that let adults continue to
receive food assistance without meeting
the work requirement but as of January
that ended 21 states had already
returned to three-month limit but 23
more joined them this year only six
states will continue to have the high
unemployment waiver that helps people
keep their food assistance oh and four
of the states implementing the
three-month limit could qualify for a
waiver but I've decided to cut people
off benefits anyway and while getting
people off benefits is good for budgets
it leaves people scrambling for other
ways to get by so in an election season
that's been defined as much by immature
potshots as the issues who's going to
speak for Americans struggling to feed
their families